Now that we understand a little
about what an outlier is,
let's take a look at
one through an example.
Here we have some income data
that's spread out in a histogram
to show how the values are distributed.
It's apparent that most of the values
representing people's income
are within the 0 to 100,000 range.
But there's one value,
someone making $1 million,
that we can see out here on the right.
That might fit with what we've
described as extreme or abnormal.
Or a great distance from most
of the values in the data set.
And if we think about it,
one instance of a report of $1
million income, compared to 40 other
values that are from zero to
100,000 is really quite abnormal.
We could probably
consider this an outlier.
But what if that single value was only
$200,000, and it looked like this?
It is far to the right, and
seems to be extreme, but $200,000,
compared to the range of zero to
100,000, isn't quite that extreme.
So is it an outlier?
It actually may not matter whether or
not we label a point as an outlier.
What does matter is that we
identify extreme data points and
understand how they impact our results.